I'm excited to talk to you today
um but I want to start um how did you
get into the reality TV production world
how did that happen oh so
um I was
um I was an actor as a as a kid and then
um started you know I was I was living
in a van and traveling doing Renaissance
a sword fighting show at Renaissance
Fairs and my
sword fighting partner and I started
making documentaries on sword swallowers
jugglers uh full contact jousters we did
a little documentary on our show which
was a sword fighting show with kids
um and then in
1998 1998
um we decided to start transitioning off
the road and my business partner at the
time had a music was a former music
executive so we started reaching out and
seeing if we couldn't
um use some of his music contacts to get
into the television business and we were
able to use some of his contacts some of
my contacts and before you know it we
were shooting uh documentaries we were
shooting music based projects we were
shooting music videos epks
um and then we started a small
production company in Toluca Lake
California in 1999 and by
2002 uh you know we had a full-blown
company and we were producing television
so it was sort of uh through that that I
ended up making TV and
um that's sort of the short short
version of it and then I got out of
Television for a couple of years my
daughter was born in 2003 and it was
really difficult for me to be on the
road so I went back into another
um business that I have a lot of
background in which is construction
management and I spent uh three years in
pers in back in construction management
um and I found those skills were very
similar to my production skills because
it's just about having a budget and a
timeline and a project to work on and
you just get it done and then uh when my
daughter turned three
um I went back on the road and and have
been sort of on the road and making TV
sense amazing that's like such a great
journey and I love when a journey starts
as a theater kid because I was also a
theater kid so yeah I get a little
background on you and I noticed that as
well I figured we'd have that in common
I love it
um so you you kind of explained a little
bit but can you kind of elaborate more
on what exactly you do as a producer
because I know that's something people
get confused about they do and so you
know as a showrunner my job is
um I'm in charge of like I'm kind of the
CEO of the show you know that's my job
is to be over top of all departments but
then once I've hired the right people
and we're up and running then my focus
has to narrow down to story and really
making sure that we're getting the best
possible version of the story that we're
there to cover and so for me that that
means just being on top of keeping that
ten thousand uh foot view of what's
going on and making sure my story team
my my producers are asking the right
questions and that my director is
getting the right shots and that we're
giving our post-production team the best
possible chance of making a really good
episode
so I'm not sure if that answers it
specifically but um you know that's once
once the logistics are up and running in
my EIC or my line producer has that in
handled then we really start
transitioning into the Story Land
because that's what the show's really
about it's not about the grips or the
electrics God bless them all and you
know it's not about what we eat for
lunch it's about what we're gonna
eventually put on television and you
know our goal is always to
um to give posts the best shot at making
the best show and I think we did a good
job this time around nice and then I
stay on through post-production as well
and you know and and manage the edit I'm
watching cuts and
um you know we're we're crafting the
story so that again what hits the TV is
the best version of what we can do I was
gonna add that because I know I know
there's so many aspects of producing so
it was nice to hear your like this is
what I do because it's yeah that's too
faceted yeah that there are and you know
that executive producer role can be many
things right it can be the guy that
finances it it could be the guy that you
know knows somebody who knows somebody
who gets it on executive producer credit
it can be you know an executive who's
really not involved in the show but for
us you know it's really important that
um you know
our role as showrunner is really defined
and we we do just that we run the show
awesome so
um you I looked at your IMDb page and I
noticed you were a producer on one of my
favorite short-lived series A Thousand
Ways To Die
my favorite my uh maybe my if I could go
back if someone said hey we're gonna
reboot Thousand Ways would you do it I
would would there be zero hesitation on
my part to go do that show again I loved
A Thousand Ways To Die because it was
like making two B movies every single
day and that production schedule is mad
we would shoot two
um
to Deaths essentially every single day
and we do that four days a week
um and we did that for several years in
a row
um that show was so much fun I got to
set people on fire blow things up
gallons of butt blood stunt performers
uh crash cars it was just an absolute
riot you know we make that show for
adolescence and that's kind of like the
vibe and we like I said I I love
thousand ways to die I'm glad you do too
because that was that was one of the
Thrills of my producing career was
making thousand ways to die and I would
go back and do it in a heartbeat I love
it because I was gonna ask you what your
favorite show to produce was
um so right Gordon's gonna kill me next
level Chef is probably number one for me
right now just because I love that show
and we are so so close to the creation
of that show and it's such a fun show to
make and for cooking shows it is such uh
I think we found a really fun way to
take a really tired format and make it
interesting and I think it's probably
the in my opinion it is the most
interesting cooking show out there
um so right now that's like number one I
love doing Kitchen Nightmares it was an
absolute Beast
but um it was so fun to work with Gordon
on that intimate level you know it's not
Gordon on a shiny floor it's just and
it's not Chef Ramsay it's just a guy
named Gordon who knocks on a front door
walks into your restaurant tries to help
you out so
um I would say you know next level chef
and then Thousand Ways To Die number one
and two and then Kitchen Nightmares Of
course
first
it's the best one because that's the one
that's coming back and it's coming back
is the one that's coming back like
almost a decade right yeah almost a
decade almost 10 years that's crazy so
what why why now great question and
that's a question we had to ask
ourselves and for Gordon the I think it
was seeing the world post pandemic
realizing how hard the restaurant
industry got hit harder than I think any
other industry
um and it's the one industry I think
that has changed the most since covid
people's dining habits have changed
dramatically since then
um you know social media didn't exist
really 10 years ago when when this show
came about so you know people won't even
most people under 30 won't walk into a
restaurant unless they check
their Yelp reviews or their Instagram
handle or see if they're on Tick Tock
you know um delivery apps have changed
the game considerably
um so and Gordon wasn't immune to any of
this Gordon's got 75 restaurants around
the world and they all took a hit so for
him it was about getting back in the
game now to see if he could throw a
Lifeline to those restaurants that made
it through the pandemic and then also to
help some of those restaurants that have
started since then to navigate this new
world order that we're in when it comes
to the restaurant Biz and also I think
Gordon realized too that a lot of those
lessons that were beat into people's
heads over the last 10 years
have been forgotten or just you know
just practice those practices of
um
we had an unofficial motto on the show
which was uh customers shouldn't have to
pay for shitty food and that really is
how gor what Gordon feels he he he
realizes it is a privilege to feed
people from money and it really makes
him righteously angry when he walks into
a restaurant and he sees restaurant
owners and staff taking advantage of
their customers by giving them subpar
food and charging them to do it so I
think all those things definitely played
into the reason why this show is back
and it has enduring popularity I mean
you can't
for I think a more popular series than
Kitchen Nightmares you can still watch
it every single day if you want on your
TV so I think that enduring popularity
of the show certainly helps as well
absolutely especially uh
I mean we love watching him cuss people
out that's like
super fun but yeah it's nice to see the
softer side of him too like when he
really cares because he seems like a
genuine person and that it seems like he
really does care he does care he cares
so much about these restaurants and the
people in them I mean in the premiere
episode did you see the premiere episode
did you get to see Basque armina Bel Air
Diner so I mean within minutes of Gordon
coming into the restaurant and sitting
down he has grown men in tears because
he really does care and he really does
want to help and people see that in his
face you know there's
the vision of and the version of Gordon
Ramsay that is the guy on TV but when he
literally walks into your restaurant and
you call him Gordon not Chef Ramsay and
he sits down with you and he really
cares about what's going on in your
restaurant and why it's not working
it affects people in a way that is
remarkable you know they say don't meet
your Heroes and I don't think that's
ever been the case with Gordon Ramsay
that's beautiful to know like because
you it's always and lately especially I
feel like dirty things come into light
with people's favorites and that exactly
what you just said don't meet your
Heroes so it's always refreshing to hear
this person is legitimate this person is
who they say they are it's so important
right now it is I I can't agree with you
more and I think that is uh that's
Gordon in a nutshell what you see is
definitely what you get and he's also
just so incredibly gracious behind the
camera too I mean
the way that he is conscious of how
Crews should be treated you know his
high standard for food uh is equally
High when it comes to television
production and that's super important
for us to to keep that level of
production as high as uh as high as
possible it's super important to us that
makes sense that makes sense so
go forward to you gave some what else
can we look forward to this evening
this is the uh everything I think that
America loves about Kitchen Nightmares
which there are clueless owners uh
egotistical off you know off the handle
chefs
um lazy staff terrible food disgusting
kitchens and then remarkable and
life-changing transformations of not
only people but their business and I
think you're also going to see Gordon
tackle some really real world problems
that are
um are very much what's going on now
mental health in the restaurant industry
is so important to Gordon and it's not
something we shy away from it's not
something he shies away from in his
Restaurant Group he has a specific
mental health program for his restaurant
group so that
if you're not feeling it he's got ways
to help you and we like you know Gordon
really brought that with him in this and
you know there are there are definitely
um there's a huge mental strain on
people in this business and Gordon is
not afraid to talk about it he's not
afraid to embrace that and he's not
afraid to try to get People Help The
Help that they need and I think that's
something that um I think you're going
to see this go around that is
um you know that I think will resonate
with a lot of people yeah yeah we love a
true focus on mental health because it's
absolutely for the pandemic is so
important yeah and especially in the
restaurant industry where it's so high
pressure and you're in such Close
Quarters and you're often working with
family and you're working you know in a
high pressure environment
um yeah it was I it's one of the things
that I really was we wanted to to put a
focus on it and you know
we definitely found people who who
needed the help and I and I'm hoping
they got it amazing well I'm hoping I I
know just from hearing everything you're
describing I'm probably going to be
crying when I watch it on September 25th
yeah September 25th we air our very
first episode which is Bel Air Diner it
is a family-run uh 24-hour diner in
Queens New York it has been a staple in
the neighborhood for almost 40 years and
it uh it is now run by two brothers who
just are absolutely at war with each
other
um and that just comes from being kids
who grew up together and working with
your older brother and feeling like
you're you know not respected or valued
in the restaurant and Gordon has to work
hard to get these two brothers back on
the same page and also get their parents
to step away these are 40 year old men
who are definitely ready to run this
restaurant and having mom and dad there
undermining their every move is uh is
something that Gordon had to deal with
as well so that's one I think um
in episode 2 Basque 46 we have a chef
who calls himself The Culinary gangster
uh and I think you'll find that to be
um a very funny episode and an episode
where
like you said you love to watch Gordon
chew people out but he doesn't
I think people love it because it's
righteous indignation right it's
everything that you want to say and and
Gordon gets to say it and I think that's
the one thing that people love and of
course we've got some absolutely
disgusting kitchens and some things that
should never be in a refrigerator that
are in a refrigerator I think the
meat-free the meat refrigerator in the
Bel Air Diner goes down in history as
one of uh as definitely one of the um
if there's a hall of Shame of Kitchen
Nightmares it's definitely going to be a
first round ballot inductee for sure and
it's not the only one we find so there's
something I think for everyone and we
also have an incredible variety of
restaurants and I think that's one of
the reasons that we've picked the area
that we picked was we knew we could get
a variety of restaurants
um that were reflective of uh of the
country as well you know I think
everyone in all corners of the country
will will identify with not only the
types of restaurants but the people as
well and I I think it'll resonate
for sure awesome well I'm excited to
watch
um David it's been so amazing being able
to
touch former into another yeah indeed of
course uh Kitchen Nightmares again
September 25th looking for September
25th
thank you David
thank you as well I really appreciate it